[Music]  barges large in fact tall is large and  grande is Spanish for large mentees the  only one that doesn't mean  [Music]  let's drink I like it I know it's great  no though  [Music]  yep should [ __ ]  [Music]  damn Jimmy is some serious gourmets  [Music]  I'd like a glass of water we have  blueberry raspberry ginseng sleepytime  green tea green tea with lemon green tea  with lemon and honey liver disaster  ginger with honey ginger powe honey  vanilla almond white truffle blueberry  chamomile Vanara walnut constant comment  and program  [Music]  you seem like an [ __ ] so I'm gonna  give you the smallest croissant  it's the one thing in my life that I can  control  [Music]